[Musique]
voir les enfants bonsoir pas trop je
descend vite chez mes deux petits amis
ils vont nous raconter une histoire du
petit chat oui vas-y vite north vous
savez il est très amusant ce petit chat
bon le shell europe 1 tout de suite a
trop à tout de suite le nours hop hop
hop hop hop hop hop hop au
bon soir les enfants
as tu été sage aujourd'hui
retrait ça on va raconter une histoire
connue elle encourt une du petit chat
je vous écoute
c'est de nous a dit la maman chat à ce
petit chat est allé d'un troc talent
gros sur l'année trois coups sur les
horreurs et toi course au petit matin et
c'est toi la défaite le château a
regardé l'année il a bayer qui s'est
couché en amour et à fermer les i
mais la maman chat a voulu faire une
surprise à son fils chat oui
ça fait que souvent la nuit son chaton
se lève pour jouer avec la lui et
l'attraper et elle a déposé près de son
fish un gros ballon rond et jaune comme
la lune un mois je continue elle s'est
couchée et elle sait pas dormi a moins
été chaque avait plus envie de jouer
qu'à dormir a ouvert à nay il a vu le
ballon lui les deux très bien lui dans
la maison
cette fois je vais bien m'amuser il
top-top avec ses petites pas il a essayé
de l'attraper alors le ballon lui n'a
retenu sur le board et la fne et les
poubelles dans le jardin ou oraux au cou
le chaton très en colère en fait le gros
dos il a sauté lui aussi par la fenêtre
sur le ballon mon corps bourbon
avec ses petites pattes
[Musique]
le petit chat curieux sifa tulard veille
à tous les chats du quartier ou au coco
car maman est venue le chercher lui a
donné trois coups de salengro sur
l'année trois coups sur les horreurs la
main ils ont fait ensemble une belle
partie de ballon le point ils sont
couchés la lune brillait dans le ciel tl
risée en les regardant
on je me suis bien amusé
sacré petit chat et hop avec ses petites
pattes
mais où sont ils donc passé une
bonne nuit les enfants
là j'éteins la lumière
à demain
on y croise non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
elle était très jolie cette histoire
tient un chat melon patron ce mois
nounours
je vous ai bien d'attraper ah ça oui ah
non en route gros vasseur
bonne nuit les enfants miaou miaou
fait de port
[Musique]
e
[Applaudissements]
vaud
oh
on
e
[Musique]